how did you go Eden Disney
World all right T where we at Disney
World so happy you know we're passing
the signs like I had like a little tear
come out of my eye cuz
[Music]
like I want to go to a for
Mom I found the airport
here we going to go the airport and I
going to see you I going to see you
right
[Music]
[Applause]
how was it like hanging out with
Aiden how being a big brother would be
like don't be sad a is really sad he
doesn't want to to leave we're going to
be back soon okay okay you can visit us
okay I love you say bye to
Primo give your Primo a
hug I'm going to see you later okay come
visit us in La we'll see you soon okay
Aiden high five it was fun had fun tying
your shoes and learning you want to look
at
[Music]
you oh my God
I hate
crying hello bye bye what was it like
saying goodbye to your cousin sad you
was sad how come I want to miss him
you're going to miss him yeah cuz I love
him he's my pretty you really got to
know him this this trip huh yeah did he
annoy you sometimes
sometimes I regret it you regret being
annoyed by him Y how come what is that
what do regret mean I regret means uh
you wish you weren't so annoyed by him
yeah yeah I regret it yeah now you miss
him didn't break your heart to see him
[Applause]
cry thank we're going to come back soon
really soon okay we're going to come
back breaks my
heart I know baby I'm
sorry
are you and I hold you oh yeah a too oh
my
baby's is it cold yes I got to zip on my
[Music]
jacket really cold it's a nice change
but it kind of smacks you in the face
with it prepared too used to warm
weather La weather's pretty warm Miami
is really warm and then you come here
and kind of just smacks him in the face
this one's heavy to oh w why is it so
light now oh cuz you're wearing it
oh good morning good morning from Dallas
teas dasas yes yeah the Double L should
be a y in Spanish but anyways we're
going to San Antonio with the whole Chan
Clan Texas road trip going to swing down
San Antonio and then we're going to head
up to Austin good old Capal Texas yeah
we got the the whole CH clan in here
Ola hola where's
Isaac Hi and then we have Diana and
Carrie's going to be driving so I'm I'm
really excited I've been wanting to get
to know other Texan cities cuz the only
city I know is Dallas cuz it's the only
city that we come to I'm ready for this
adventure let me continue my sleep I
know we woke up early no we went to bit
late we slept very little mommy you the
iPad in the backpack yeah Casey's
backpack I didn't bring my backpack
though uh-oh we don't have the
iPad just kidding so why is the iPad so
important I don't know cuz oh that is
the question of the century yeah why is
the iPad so important yeah because you
you do business with it no you run all
your all your businesses with it no it's
because it entertains Me Entertain You
okay entertaining it makes turns go fast
oh [__] I need to buckle up oh we got to
buckle all right but first we're going
to take a pit stop at Mickey days need
to get some breakfast why am I the order
person all sudden everyone's giving me
the orders now I everyone's telling you
what to order we'll play until you guys
are finished ordering yes go have a
childhood my
[Music]
love
show that I long for
youo
o so
many
we
have
[Music]
I we are in new bronzville Texas in
between Austin and San Antonio we're
here at bies which is like a super I
don't know what this place plac is it's
kind of like a gas station kind of like
a Walmart kind of like a mall kind of
like a 7-Eleven kind of like a all the
above convenience store gas station I
don't know but it's huge never been here
before they're only in Texas they have a
little Beaver as their little logo and I
really like that guy it's a cute little
guy it's cuter than
you this place is huge this place is
huge they really take on the whole
everything's bigger in Texas it's a
glorified gas station yeah basically
it's a gas station Heaven pretty cool
I'm actually kind of amazed the
bathroom's like ginormous you can you
can like break dance in the middle of it
I felt weird shooting footage in the
bathroom I stopped shooting footage in
the bathroom and people starting to look
weird at me but the bathroom's huge I
don't know like Isaac was so wow just by
looking at the bathrooms right look at
these these are awesome what are those
barbecue sauces hot sa something like
that this guy has like little teeth on
it or something they even have pickled
quail EGS I guess it's almost kind of
like a nov store like I've never seen
deer snack sticks and you know you're in
Texas hello welcome to bies home of the
Beaver greatest competing store in the
world 120 bus wining service orning
restroom 6800 fet www.bet.com have AER
to
day that was awesome thank you Tiff you
missed out she didn't need to use the
restroom so she didn't go in yeah it
just have like the world's largest
strongest bladder I don't know every
time we go on vacations I'm always the
one that good job that can hold it in
the long
I don't know how you guys lasted uh New
Year in New York in New York I have been
wearing a diaper or something uh we we
were we were dying what do you think it
is inside what does it look like here it
looks like 7eleven on crack that's what
it looks like yes it's 7-Eleven meets
Costco oh what and the guy when you walk
in the door he T like a auction ear
like man I guess I really did miss out I
just thought it was really funny when we
first pulled up mama Chan was like we're
getting gas at Chuck-E-Cheese
[Music]
San Antonio is beautiful never been here
I was like 9 years old when I last came
here if I knew it would look this pretty
I could come here more
often we're
here stretch my legs out
oh welcome to San Antonio
yo what is
[Music]
that okay living the good life
okay you want to share a cookie with me
yes
[Music]
please we got warm cookies where did you
get that
OA about the center best
SP
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
this oh man went the wrong way I was
like I'm going to get ahead of you
guys oh I can't
squeeze yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
action is a not staying with us she's
not what what staying with your parents
a snap what does that mean
nothing ooh conjoining
rooms fancy look the microwave the
microwave I calls it a microwave all the
time yeah we when we were on the cruise
he saw the same thing he's like cool on
a microwave just got into the hotel room
super excited to be in San Antonio cuz I
haven't been in San Antonio since I was
like N I have no recollection really of
what the city is like but driving
through it I was like oh my God this
looks so like European and so like
romantic yay
romantico all right we are on our way to
the Riverwalk of San
[Music]
[Applause]
Antonio oh ducky that's that's a lot of
duckies how cute you call them
[Applause]
[Music]
duckies what are you
doing
people are going to think he really runs
like that he's just kidding guys okay
Isaac has several different ways of
running the newest one the newest
addition to his lineup of running
style what's the old
one you like coming up with different
ways to run huh is like yeah that
[Music]
one what do you think of San Antonio it
is really romantic it's very romantic I
like it so far I mean we've only seen a
tiny little patch but I know it keeps
going and going going and
going all right we're going to go eat
next to the Alamo instead instead of
eating at the Riverwalk because the
Riverwalk is packed like a 2hour wait
it's not worth it and we finally get to
see the
[Music]
Alo whoa whoa don't close on me
yeah
oh I can see the Elmo what is the Elmo
Elmo
a
a inside your mind time Miss what are we
doing now we're checking out the elm
after
dinner go ins mind and find
time Isaac gets under my Poncho he looks
up at me he goes mommy you're pregnant
but your baby's already out talking and
I'm telling him 9 years ago today I was
still pregnant so crazy you're almost
hitting that decade time flew by so fast
guys if you guys if you guys have kids
you know in the future you don't have
kids now and you have kids in the future
just know that time goes by so fast and
people out there that do have kids are
probably like for sure agreeing with me
right now you see your kid grow up in an
instant it's so so sad how fast they
grow so cherish every single moment you
have with your kids cuz it goes by so
fast I'm going to ask the other parents
do you feel like I grew up too
fast
yeah it is I want I wish you a see a
baby I am ready for my grand baby oh
that's what it is now huh you moved on
to the next best thing what did she say
she said she's ready for the grand
babies Oh couple
Warriors okay okay let's put it this way
I'm I'm ready for the wedding yeah all
right all right step by step yeah there
we go what years do you miss the most
with me with you yeah pinpoint one phase
in my life that you're like I want to
see that Casey the most which one is it
I would say uh like four five years old
cuz you you know more stuff you know you
kind of try to be independent you know
doing stuff like tying shoes taking
shower yourself and stuff like that you
know and uh I we can have a conversation
I enjoy those time actually I'm growing
up with you throughout your whole life
you know cuz you know immigrant from
another country so a lot of stuff I
don't know the school system and
everything but you give me the
opportunity to learn like I'm going to
school with you you know I volunteer at
PTA I do a lot of stuff for the school
so I'm kind of experiencing going to
school with you so I learned a lot you
know so I'm very thankful very grateful
and you are my first born so I learned
everything with you you my
experiments with everything so when krie
come along it's much easier for me even
though he's a more difficult child but
that prepare me to handle him a little
bit more you know if he's my first born
I would be like oh my God I don't want
any more okay do you think your children
grew up too fast yes too fast really
fast Pi a time period of my life to
relive again any any phase any year of
my life what what years would those be I
think 16 17 years old really yeah that's
difficult that was a very difficult few
years I know but you were behaving well
overall and you begin to think about
your future and what you want to do and
you are doing things you are proving it
to me that your certainty how what you
want to be who you want to be you know
and you're making it right now you're
making some progress you're not there
yet but you're making some progress
thanks for letting me know I'm not there
yet I still remember hey Daddy can you
buy me a editing software and I say what
do you use it for and then you said hey
I'm going to make some movie and I need
the editing software and I said okay
it's only 99 bucks I can afford it and
here you go what you are right now $99
investment turned into this
exactly it was awesome it was 16 years
old when you were asking me for that's
why I think that year is the year that
you make the determination where who you
want to be thank you for the editing
software only 99 bucks I got pay back
already all right we're do what are we
doing we're about to do a mirror
mze W the where are we going Isaac okay
we not going that way we not going this
way oh I see
me who I'm tripping out I am tripping
out lost scar wait where are you oh wait
no that's you I was like wait is that
you or is that you I thought that was
that was F he came this way oh yeah a
spot over there can you go straight
there I don't know let's try it here's a
mirror wait is this is this it okay all
right you having fun I think you having
fun is that us over there or is that
someone
else who wait the beginning wrong way oh
we the the other way what did he say he
said wrong
way how do you get out of this place so
we wer we weren't trying to beat the
maze too fast cuz you wanted to get our
money's worth but now we're actually
stuck in here this reminds me of Enter
the Dragon this way this way this
way right here oh that's you I was like
wait is that you or is that you this way
this way this way oh
man again again wait what am I doing oh
you're a real person
[Music]
okay
we finally found it finally hey pretty
girl pretty girl me yeah you what's up
what are you doing H relaxing after a
very fun eventful beautiful day in San
Antonio yeah so now we're getting ready
for bed Isaac's going to sleep over with
Mama Chan and papa Chan as he does every
time we take a trip it's so cute yeah I
think they like um spending time with
him too I think you know obviously it's
the closest thing they have to a
grandchild oh man I'm excited for for
the day that we expand our family though
yeah that's it for today you're so
[Music]
cute know you got
so 1 2
[Music]
I can't model you know I get weird when
I
model
oh oh yeah so what are we doing today so
today we're kind of spending our morning
here in San Antonio and then once we
finish having breakfast then we're going
to be heading over to Austin and we're
going to get to explore Austin for the
rest of the day so right now we're uh
we're looking for a restaurant cuz we're
hungry this is nice this is so
nice she picked up on that no Joe has
influenced the way we speak so much well
if you're really trying to imitate Joe
it's m awesome mother awesome m
m that's how you everything's mother I
know that all right so we're finally
doing what we wanted to do yesterday
which was to eat on the Ripper
walk cheers y'all to have happiness
happiness what are we about to do now
we're on our way to the car to go to
Austin really excited to get to know
Austin cuz that's the one city I always
hear about in Texas especially with like
South Southwest and everything and then
because Jess jica she lived in Austin I
just want to get to know that City so
we're on our way there I'm going to
spend the rest of the day in
Austin ready ready let's do it let's go
buy some stuff yes we we're back at day
behind you biy now I get to find out
what I missed out on last time you fell
asleep I just woke up from the MP it's
the same biy as we
went what do you think yeah Texas does
everything bigger right what's the thing
yeah everything's bigger in Texas look
at that this like a Walmart I need to
wake up you get some coffee what's up La
hey what's up homes this would have
worked if you had your head shaved still
you threw your hair out okay all right
Cho time over all right let's get it icy
get it icy all right I follow
[Music]
you okay you know what let's ask Mommy
what size to get cuz uh smallest
[Music]
one
nice give you a
[Music]
lid they have their brand of everything
like spicy pickled garlic biy
brand you like fudge I didn't realize I
like fudge until that time that we came
to Fort Worth many years ago then I
bought some fudge I'm like oh fudge is
delicious M like it mhm I like fudge a
lot too it's just that when I eat fudge
I eat like two bites and I'm done yeah
it's really it's really sweet it's
really
[Music]
good we are now in Austin
Texas I'm still really tired from the
ride I have like no energy dude you
really need to use the HEI oh my gosh
Come here look at these lips sorry I
couldn't do it in the car I was sitting
down yeah you can that's the best time
to do it yeah oh man it's a good thing
you don't have a girlfriend cuz she will
not want to K you right now oh look at
me I'm using it too nice CH team CH
Team all right we are now in Austin
Texas being here has made me realize I
know nothing about Texas because
everyone in California comes to me for
Texas information and yeah I left here
when I was like 18 theoretically I was
still like a kid and uh didn't really
get to explore much of Texas as a
grownup and so all I do know of Texas
and Austin is just pretty much the
perspective of what a kid would know
[Applause]
water
[Music]
ooh
do some modeling
[Music]
shots I like how this zipper got stuck I
only have three three poses this one
this one and this one that's
[Music]
it it's so weird it's really silly
especially if people stare it's
[Music]
okay our love is a very urgent FL that
they had to take
no no yeah flaming hot get it okay okay
all right all right fail
work look I just want to get a shot of
this look really cool for a second look
really really cool I don't know what to
do to look
[Music]
cool this is me trying to look cool yeah
I just look like I have a fart stuck or
something we're at the hotel now
right what did I grab the batteries from
the other Hotel I grabbed them yeah my
hard just thing one of those problems
you have when you're traveling with so
much equipment that you just can't keep
track of laptop laptop charger hard
drive other hard drive hard drive cords
hard drive other cords camera camera
lens camera cap camera battery camera
charger other battery other battery
other battery other camera charger hard
to S wow this room is nice you guys have
balconies oh we do yeah show me oh
cool do we have a view a view of the
parking lot not bad
uh we have quite an emergency oh we have
a guest unwanted guest an unwanted guest
tell me about this guest that you found
uh so I was here trying to check out the
view which I just see a big mirror and
there's like this really giant flying
kind of bug oh my God that's huge it's
it's got a yellow belly oh my Gody to
grab
it oh D you're brave what is that Take
It Outside put it back in the wo I don't
know what this is like a beetle keeping
Austin Weird all right see you later go
away okay we're good does it fly I don't
know I just dropped anyway so we're
going to give this room over to Carrie
and Diana and we're going to head to our
room now our actual room enjoy you know
what's funny when we were in San Antonio
the first room we walked into casy and I
were like cool this is our room and then
we we set our bags down and it's like oh
wait would you rather like switch rooms
and then we ended up switching rooms
like three times three times
so then now we settle down in this room
and it's like oh wait do you guys
actually want to take the other room cuz
they're conjoining they're conjoin
they're adjoining adjoining joining is
it adjoining or conjoining I don't know
they're next to each other conjoining is
when it's like actually stuck together
join Twins and en joining like adjacent
so the reason why we're switching is
because Isaac wants to be next door to
us obviously so that's why we're
switching rooms got it
English and it looks the same now we
actually have a we have the can joining
door the ad joining door ad joining ad
joining ad joining ad joining ad joining
that's how I studied when I was a
student it's all about repetition you
know what was so funny Tiff what so I
posted on Twitter uh I was asking people
what was good to eat in Austin but then
before I could even suggest any spot to
my family my dad just goes we're going
Chinese food tonight sorry for any of
y'all that actually responded and uh
tried offering some help but we're eaing
Chinese food tonight in Austin when it
comes to Papa Chan it's always Chinese
food ah but you know what though he's
put up with us eating American food
steak and fries hamburgers for a couple
days so we'll entertain some Chinese
food
tonight what you're cold no it smells
horrible it smells horrible why that's
mean this kid has no respect do no
[Music]
matters how you like the soup
Isaac hey good job for trying I was
honestly honestly expecting a it's I
know me
too
man this is some good Chinese food the
real Chinese food none of that Panda
Express
stuff it's my favorite kind of Chinese
your favorite kind of Chinese food is
pan Express stuff that's American food
who cares who
cares Isaac it's so tight that you know
how to use chopsticks that is so awesome
look at you look at that look at that
look at that wo oh so close you got it
you got it don't give up
carer does Isaac remind you of you when
you were a kid thank you for the rice by
the way yeah I guess that's why I really
like Isaac you relate to him I relate to
him so I can't be mad for half the stuff
that he does I get it I'm just like I I
feel like you're still doing some of the
stuff yeah so growing up my brother he
was really picky with food didn't like
to eat anything couldn't eat a whole lot
behaved in very similar ways it was
bouncing off the walls and I even
accidentally C Isaac like whenever every
time I call Isaac I want to say but yeah
but I'm like a it's Isaac it's Isaac
today I almost called you
Isaac I did it just
now whenever you frustrate me and I'm
just like ISAC I mean he it always comes
out he'll frustrate me and be like hey I
mean Isaac it's like the people that
frustrate you in the same way or comes
from a same similar place in your heart
yeah you you get their names confused
especially your parents cuz your parents
named you guys literally only one letter
apart so I could hear them all the time
Carrie Casey Casey Carrie get him
confused theat I'm going to my like his
name no he just thinks I'm as cute as
them I like it positive thinking all
right let's eat what are you
doing beeping or beat
[Applause]
boxing I asked him I'm like what are you
doing he's like like beeping I'm like
you mean beatboxing he's like
yeah goes back I like this dressure
where he was
like I snapped
[Applause]
it what are you
doing beeping or
beatboxing cute right here yeah the last
frame hey guys so today we're trying
something new and we're going to be
doing our very first Challenge on on
this channel you've been telling me
you've been wanting to do challenges
right mhm how come because as I have
seen in JK party I just thought I want
to try something new on YouTube